en este vídeo haré algunos ejemplos
sobre el teorema del residuo básicamente
el teorema del residuo nos dice que si
tienes un polinomio fx y lo divides
entre un factor lineal que tiene la
forma x menos a si haces esa división
sintética y encuentras el residuo el
teorema nos dice que será lo mismo a que
si sustituimos a en la función original
ok entonces veamos tres ejemplos en el
primer ejemplo tenemos 3x cúbica menos
2x cuadrada más x menos 6 esto sería
nuestra fx y en este caso la vamos a
dividir entre x menos 4 entonces este
número es lo que correspondería a
nuestro valor de a entonces si tenemos
la función f x que es igual a 3 x cúbica
menos 2 x cuadrada más x menos 6 si
queremos encontrar el residuo al dividir
entre x menos 4 pues simplemente vamos a
sustituir
por 4 y así nos queda tres por cuatro al
cubo menos dos por cuatro al cuadrado
más cuatro menos seis y esto es igual a
tres por vamos a ver 4 al cubo es igual
a 64 y 4 al cuadrado es 16 por menos 2
eso es igual a 32 y más 4 menos 6 es
igual a menos 2 y luego 3 por 64 es
igual a 192 192 menos 32 menos 2
entonces 192 menos 32 menos 2 es igual a
158 así que en este caso al hacer la
división el residuo será igual a 158 ok
hagamos el siguiente
observen que aquí tenemos menos 4x
cúbica más 8x cuadrada más 12 x + 16
entre x más 2 ahora observen que podemos
escribir el denominador como x menos
menos dos porque miren en el primer
ejemplo aquí teníamos menos 4 pero lo
que sustituimos fue 4 positivo entonces
aquí tenemos dos positivos pero en
realidad vamos a sustituir menos 2 en la
función del número 2
entonces si ahora nuestra función fx es
igual a menos 4 x cúbica más 8 x
cuadrada más 12 x 16 al sustituir x x
menos 2 bueno entonces nos queda menos 4
x menos 2 al cubo más 8 x menos 2 al
cuadrado más 12 x menos dos más
16 ok veamos si podemos hacerlo menos 2
al cubo por menos 4 es igual a 32 y
luego menos 2 al cuadrado es 4 que por 8
también es 32 y después 12 por menos 2
es igual a menos 24 más 16 entonces 32
más 32 son 64 menos 24 son 40 y más 16
es igual a 56 entonces en este caso el
residuo es igual a 56 positivo y de una
vez hagamos el último ejercicio no se ve
tan mal tenemos x a la sexta más 4x a la
quinta más 9 x cúbica menos 4x cuadrada
más 10 entre x 1 entonces nuevamente
podemos escribir esto como x menos -1 y
esto es nuestra y nuevamente simplemente
sustituimos eso en esta función
esta es nuestra fx y por lo tanto
podemos decir que f de menos uno es
igual a menos uno elevado a la sexta
potencia más cuatro por menos uno a la
quinta más nueve por menos uno al cubo
menos cuatro por menos uno al cuadrado
más diez entonces un número negativo
elevado a un número par es igual a un
número positivo uno positivo pero si lo
elevamos a un número impar seguirá
siendo un número negativo así que nos
queda menos cuatro menos nueve y este
será uno positivo que por menos 4 nos da
menos 4 + 10 ok entonces tenemos menos 4
y menos 4 da menos 8 menos 9 es igual a
menos 17 más 10 nos queda menos 7 y más
uno es igual a menos 6 si mi aritmética
es correcta así que en este último
ejemplo al hacer esta división
obtendremos un residuo de menos 6
puede hacer la aritmética